يؤثر داء صحه من تاثيرا كثيرا على اي
مرحله عمريه لكن الاشخاص المصابين بدايه
زهايمر مبكر يواجهون بعض التحديات الفريده
من نوعها جاء الزهيم المبكر بشكل غير شائع
من الخرف ويصيب الاشخاص الذين تبلغوا
اعمارهم اقل من 65 عاما يصبح 5 الى 6% من
الاشخاص المصابين بداء الزهايمر بالاعراض
قبل سن الخامسه 62 ويشعر معظم الاشخاص
المصابون باعراض المرض عندما تتلوح
اعمارهم بين الثلاثين والستين عاما لا
يعرف الخبراء تحديدا السبب وراء اصابته
بعض الاشخاص بالمرض في سن المبكره عن
غيرهم لكنهم يرشحون حدوث طفرات في احد
الجينات التي يمكن ان تورث لفرد اخر من
العائله وقد تدل اصابه احد الوالدين
مبكر على احد هذه التغيرات في الجينات
بخصائص مختلفه قليلا هذا الاشخاص الاصغر
سنا والتي قد تؤدي الى تشخيص الخاطئ
وتاخير العلاج المناسب الامر الذي ينتج عن
اثار سلبيه على جوده الحياه ويعد التشخيص
ضروري لاتخاذ القرارات المهمه في المسائل
الماليه والقانونيه قبل فوات الاوان فقد
يخسر المصمون على قاتم او وظائفهم
وبالتالي فقدان لمصدر دخليهم نتيجه تشخصهم
بهذا المرض بينما لا يزالون في سن العمل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]